working for the scp foundation is no
walk in the park you're forced to remain
under a veil of secrecy at all times
risking your life every single day
contending with dangerous and
inexplicable anomalies and sometimes you
have to do things that you are not proud
of whether it's forcing others to
collect the dangerous y909 compound from
scp-3000
the giant eel responsible for creating
the chemicals and amnestics or engaging
in a variety of innumerable unscrupulous
activities all done in service of
maintaining normalcy the nature of work
at the foundation invites difficult
problems with no clear solutions moral
dilemmas challenging enough to give a
philosopher an aneurysm and enough
trauma that amnestics becomes standard
issue tools in a foundation personnel's
arsenal not just to wipe the minds of
others but also to use on themselves
allowing their mental states a reprieve
from the atrocities they may or may not
have committed but that's part of the
job description you know what you're
signing up for when it comes to the scp
foundation even if you're unsure of what
your job will entail what you need to
understand is that when you work for the
scp foundation every day could
potentially be your last and if it's not
yours it's almost definitely someone
else's maybe that's what the recruiting
officers tell prospective researchers
and agents to really cheer them up
sometimes carrying out the foundation's
morally questionable acts results in or
in some cases requires one of the most
irreversible permanent actions taking a
life
death is a common sight at the
foundation your job is constantly at
risk of prematurely disappearing due to
one faulty containment chamber leading
to a full-scale breach or just having
the bad luck that comes with being one
of the first ones to explore a
mysterious location before all of the
anomalous effects within are mapped out
being assigned to a dangerous anomaly
will practically ensure you'll see death
and potentially be the cause of it
d-class personnel are the foundation's
lab rats reportedly sourced from death
row inmates and other unsavory
characters these guys do the jobs that
no one else wants to do whether it's
cleaning the containment chamber of the
hostile neck snapping scp-173
or venturing into the dark unending
depths of scp-087
staircase there's no shortage of
incredibly dangerous tasks for the
foundation to hand out with so much
death and destruction surrounding them
it shouldn't come as a surprise that the
foundation initiated project demeron to
research what happens after death if
anything but that's another story
entirely let's keep talking about
d-class personnel there's always someone
behind the d-class the one giving orders
and when those orders result in a loss
of life it's going to weigh down on that
person's consciousness death row inmate
or not sometimes amnestics are enough to
smooth it over sometimes not but no one
can say that the foundation does not
have an insensitivity to death it only
takes one look at an scp file's cold
clinical delivery of a brutal experiment
gone wrong to realize this names listed
names redacted sometimes it really feels
like all these deaths are just numbers
and statistics for the foundation to
report maybe the d really does stand for
disposable on one hand it's
understandable the foundation is an
institution of science and the need for
reports to be as accurate detailed and
professional as possible outweighs the
sorrow and sadness that comes with the
loss of life but on the other hand would
it hurt these guys to show some humanity
for once it's always a crowd pleaser
when the foundation comes down from its
high horse and goes the extra mile to
show how much they care like when the
legendary
d-14134 single-handedly saved the world
from the deadly scp-1983
a barn house infested with vicious heart
collecting entities that even the
foundation had difficulty dealing with
sure d14134 died but he was posthumously
awarded the foundation's star for his
efforts the second ever d-class to do so
okay maybe the foundation needs a bit of
work on figuring out how to best honor
its most respected members but is this
cold detached outlook just a result of
years of exposure to the hardships of
anomalous containment or is there
something larger at play this
scp-001 proposal just may provide your
answer as we've explained before there
is no single scp-001
but many an old foundation legend passed
down between personnel says that many of
the highly classified 001 files are fake
mere diversions to confuse the true001
a file so secretive that the foundation
resorted to deception on a scale untold
just to hide its existence but that's
just a rumor the truth is that the zero
zero one database is composed of dozens
of proposals all of which details
objects of high importance and standing
to the foundation at large from tufto's
proposal which details the surprising
history between the threshold between
antiquity and modernity the scarlet king
to ball's proposal which focuses around
a sheaf of papers with the capability to
create anomalies these files don't shy
away from covering big questions and
delivering even bigger answers but as
always keep in mind that due to the
inherent mystery and veil of secrecy
involved in an scp-001 file not
everything may be true or appear as
simple as it seems the anomaly we'll be
looking at today is solvex's
scp-001 proposal which on the outset
looks deceptively simple
scp-001 is an antique lamp like one
you'd see at a pawn shop or in your
grandparents attic while the material of
the lamp is decidedly not anomalous the
fuel space is filled with class a
ectomorphs an anomalous particle
foundation researchers have hypothesized
that the presence of these particles
allow for the lamp's flames to burn
indefinitely and an experiment testing
these capabilities lasted for over a
month with no signs of extinction
viewing its flames triggers an anomalous
effect the suppression of responsibility
for deaths caused by the viewer that's
right
scp-001 extinguishes responsibility for
your actions specifically those that
have resulted in the deaths of others
while your conscience may be lightened
this object acts only as a distraction
the memory of the deaths still exist if
mentioning such a death absolutely
cannot be avoided viewers of scp-001
will instead describe it with a
euphemism ever wonder why the foundation
uses the terms neutralized or terminated
so much that's because scp-001
is required viewing for members of the
foundation initially following the
item's retrieval in texas
scp-001 was catalogued as a simple
anomaly a light that did not burn out
its secondary effect of alleviating
responsibility was discovered after the
fact no doubt after some researchers
felt unusually calm about sending a few
individuals to their deaths sorry i
meant terminations in service of the
foundation one day its effects transfer
even to pictures and videos of
scp-001's flames which are distributed
to all foundation personnel under a
directive referred to as the acquittal
protocol discovering
scp-001 was truly beneficial to the
early foundation whose personnel
understandably struggled with having to
take lives and make hard decisions
before the discovery of this object
those working for organizations
investigating the anomalous had to live
with untold atrocities weighing down on
them take for example another scp-001
proposal the factory one of the many
conflicting varying origin stories for
the foundation the factory was one of
the first anomalies investigated by the
foundation before it had even been
established as the foundation a horrific
industrial factory filled to the brim
with tortured workers burning machines
and the stench of death while the
factory was dealt with to the best of
the early foundation's abilities those
involved in the operation were scarred
and rightfully so perhaps to older
generations of foundation employees who
lived through horrors unimaginable
exposing the entire organization to this
scp-001 lamp was the right thing to do
to spare the future generations of
foundation workers from having to live
with the consequences of their actions
but in doing so in utilizing an anomaly
on such a large group of people against
their will what is the foundation
robbing from the people who work for it
as overseer 05-1 once described it in a
correspondence letter regarding scp-001
i still regret that people who join us
to protect mankind from abnormalities
are changed into abnormalities and
contained as such but still we must keep
going until we find a better way than
this method we must always do our best
in a way the transformation of the very
morality of a human being is an anomaly
in itself by negating the effects of
witnessing death you deliberately create
behavior that goes against hundreds of
thousands of years of biological wiring
those exposed to scp-001 are changed
fundamentally metaphorically this is the
curse of the foundation researcher sworn
to protect sworn to die in the dark in
silence so that others may live in the
light and like all vows of secrecy it
comes with a cost it shouldn't come as a
surprise that a large number of
foundation personnel work with the
organization as a generational calling
take the bright family for instance once
you're in there's no getting out and
it's a lot easier to live as a family
with knowledge of the foundation than
someone's parent attempting to balance a
double life as a senior researcher for
some members of the foundation they were
thrown into this life before they were
even born and anomalies like scp-001
only cement the line that divides an
ordinary person from those working
behind the veil the foundation secures
contains and protects but the people
making up the massive organization are
just that people by furthering the
divide between the general public and a
member of the scp foundation you only
ensure 105-1 already knew he continued
organizations that protect mankind from
anomalous objects have existed all over
the world for a long time although there
have been numerous ways of protection it
is indispensable to gain knowledge of
anomalies and the processes inevitably
include experiments using living human
beings this varies depending on times
and regions such as criminals slaves
different ethnic groups and so on
nevertheless it is still largely eroded
in the minds of the researchers some
people could not bear their sins and
threw themselves into the sea another
person eliminated the distinction
between life and death to keep his peace
of mind but then he killed his family
due to a slight quarrel i told many
personnel repeatedly that these
sacrifices led to protecting the world
such words are however only so effective
and many personnel's hearts were
understandably broken but i found that
lamp the circumstances were coincidental
but its effect is noteworthy researchers
have been able to study gruesome
anomalies without so much a care in the
world as a result their work efficiency
dramatically increased and the damage
caused by abnormalities was soon
negligible of course the feelings
remained but there were measures in
place now amnestics advanced anomalous
therapies if we wanted we could remove
the very emotion of sadness from a man's
psyche but we couldn't we're already far
too gone and the lasting effects of this
lamp weigh on my mind the way it is
those who abandon their responsibility
for death by themselves become
heterogeneous in daily life where
general morality exists they had become
impossible to live among the general
public institutions such as the ethics
committee the board of directors
responsible for maintaining the
foundation's moral integrity can only do
so much when surrounded by the amount of
death the average secure facility deals
with this is likely why directives such
as the acquittal protocol are greenlit
it doesn't entirely negate the effects
of death but it works pretty well as a
cheap simple organization-wide mnistic
pushing the uncomfortable memories and
thoughts to the back of the mind until
they're absolutely needed and even then
making sure to sugarcoat them in the
most detached robotic way possible so
the next time you think you want to
submit a job application to the scp
foundation
think of
scp-001 as well as all the other
difficult immoral tasks you may be asked
to perform is throwing away your
humanity in service of the goal of
containment to noble one what about
changing the impact of one of life's
most constant elements
death whatever the answer may be there's
one thing everyone can agree on the life
of foundation personnel is not for
everyone and it certainly isn't easy on
the mind now go check out scp-001 the
way the world ends reality unfolds and
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
scp animation for more wicked and wild
scp-001
possibilities